years ago you've gone on to much bigger
and better things but years ago you got
when you're getting your start you do in
the Calvin Klein ads and now Justin
Bieber has got your old gig I think we
have side by side photos there's you
there's Justin oh yeah I had that gig
briefly for three months
I'm glad the Pope didn't know you for
that yeah you know what what I mean how
do you feel about Justin Bieber doing it
as he has he reached out to you in any
way he actually you know what he is a
very nice young man he's a friend of
mine I've spent time with him he did
send me the pictures I was like you
don't send a guy pictures why did he
send you the pictures just to just you
know he was proud you know it was a big
deal for him to do and I was like you
know I am at 45 and a dad and four
husband father four I'm trying to move
away from that image right but um you
know what people give him flak for you
know being you know kind of growing up
in the spotlight and he's you know they
say has a bit of an attitude but you
look at this the look on my face I mean
I was the biggest punk in the world yeah
he's very nice young and polite compared
to what I was you look like you're just
causing yourself pain by squeezing yours
that is the face you make when you
squeeze your sack like that well you
know I've well I can't say I've done
worse things but yeah that was uh not
one of my proudest moments
you